[Music]
this morning our series eye on earth
looks at the punishing drought gripping
much of the western u.s
scientists are calling it a mega drought
brought on by climate change now look at
this map the latest u.s drought monitor
map shows
large areas of the southwest are
exceptionally dry
that's never good the worst category is
taking a dramatic toll on the
colorado river system that provides
water to 40 million people in seven
different states
cbs news senior environmental
correspondent that's been tracy
traveled to the iconic hoover dam and
shows us how the federal government
may be forced to make a drastic and
historic decision
i mean it's amazing to see it up close
for more than eight decades the hoover
dam has relied on water from nevada's
lake mead
to cover up its backside but now at age
85
it finds itself uncomfortably exposed
much of the water the dam is supposed to
be holding back is gone
this is like a different world pat
mulroy is the former head of the
southern nevada water authority
she says lake mead the nation's largest
reservoir
is on track to soon hit its lowest level
ever recorded
this part of the colorado river system
is a crucial water supply for las vegas
phoenix and southern california it makes
the vast agricultural land of the desert
southwest
possible this landscape screams
problems to me i mean just look at the
bathtub rings
to me that is an enormous wake-up call
lake mead is at just 37 percent of its
capacity
it hasn't been full since back in 2000
when the water came right up to the top
of hoover dam
this is what it looks like now since
2000 lake mead has dropped 130 feet
that's hard to imagine but picture a 13
story building on top of my head
and way up there that's where the water
used to be
so you and i talked here back in 2014
and
at that time i asked you how critical a
point are we at
it's a pretty critical point if you look
at
30 feet lower now what point are we at
we're at a tipping point it's an
existential issue
for arizona for california for nevada
it is just that simple for the first
time ever the federal government is
expected to declare a water shortage
on the lower colorado river later this
summer
that will force automatic cuts to the
water supply for nevada and arizona
starting in 2022 homeowners have higher
priority and at first won't feel the
pain
as badly as farmers if we don't have
irrigation water we can't farm
dan thielander is a second generation
family farmer in arizona's penal county
the water to grow his corn and alfalfa
fields
comes from lake mead so next year we're
going to get about
25 percent less water means we're going
to have to fallow or not plant
25 percent of our land
in 2023 thielander and other farmers in
this part of arizona are expected to
lose nearly all of their water from lake
mead
so they're rushing to dig wells to pump
groundwater
to try to save their farms the future
here honestly i hate to say it but it's
pretty cloudy this is an engineering
marvel for sure
back at hoover dam facility manager mark
cook has his own concerns
lake mead has dropped so much that it's
cut the dam's hydropower output
by nearly 25 percent so these are
generating the electricity these things
yep exactly he wanted to show us the new
turbine blades they just installed
so right below us right here is that
brand new turbine designed to keep the
power flowing efficiently
at rapidly dropping lake levels at some
point the dam could stop producing
electricity altogether
our previous number was at elevation
10.50
and now we've lowered that number to
9.50 so we as we bought ourselves 100
feet
all those islands were underwater
completely submerged
pat mulroy says a rapidly retreating
reservoir may be the new normal
and the millions of people who rely on
this water supply will have to quickly
learn
to live with less of it we don't change
unless we absolutely have to
well when you look out at this lake i
think that moment of it's absolutely
necessary has arrived for cbs this
morning ben tracy
lake mead nevada wow that is an alarming
outlook from pat mulroy their tipping
point she said
yeah i think the days are upon us to
pray for rain yes